Let's do another one quiz on BTB and BHT interactions.
Again we have the same BHT, 16 entries and perfect. BTB's four entries and
perfect. Same program as before. The question for
you now is how many times do we access the BTB this time for each instruction?
So, how many times, when we fetch this instruction, do we access the BTB.
How many times, when you fetch this instruction, do we access the BTB,
and so on. Remember that these two instructions execute only once.
This loop has 100 iterations, so all these instructions execute 100 times,
except for this one, which executes 101 times. The question for you now is,
how many times do we access the BTB for each of those instructions?